der ukrainische Präsident selenski denkt
jetzt auch laut darüber nach den Chef
der Armee saluschni zu entlassen das hat
er in einem Interview mit dem
italienischen Sender Rei gesagt darüber
hinaus kann er sich vorstellen nicht nur
die militärische sondern auch die
politische Führung des Landes
auszutauschen tja was steckt dahinter
darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit
dem Militärexperten Nico lange schönen
guten Tag hallo Herr Lange warum spricht
Präsident selenski davon seinen
Armeechef loszuwerden was steckt
dahinter na es gibt immer mal wieder
Auseinandersetzung zwischen den beiden
und gibt sie auch aktuell gerade im
Bezug auf die Frage soll man jetzt
aufdevka weiter verteidigen oder soll
man sich da besser zurückziehen weil man
ja auch ressourcenprobleme hat z.B bei
Munition und es geht glaube ich generell
um die Frage wie man an diesen Krieg
herangeht vielleicht auch ein bisschen
um die Frage wer ist eigentlich dafür
verantwortlich dass die Ukraine
militärisch gerade so so in einer
schwierigen Situation ist der
ukrainische Staatspräsident ist der
gewählte Präsident der kann natürlich
den Oberbefehlshaber der Streitkräfte
entlassen und einen neuen einsetzen aber
was in der Ukraine nicht gut ankommt ist
das öffentliche Nachdenken über diese
Frage und jetzt tagelange Spekulationen
und sogar noch mit ausländischen Medien
darüber zu sprechen aber in der Ukraine
nichts Klares zu sagen also könnte man
sagen der Konflikt besteht vor allem
darin D Präsident selenski die Situation
aus seiner politischen Sicht beurteilt
und der Armeechef saluschni eben aus
militärischer Sicht und dass die
Meinungen da dann doch sehr weit
auseinander
gehen ich glaube dass diese
unterschiedlichen Perspektiven eine
Rolle spielen und das ist wenn man sich
das im Einzelnen ansieht gar nicht so
einfach zu entscheiden wer da jetzt
eigentlich recht hat also wenn general
salusni sagt wir haben zu wenig Munition
wir müssen die Front begradigen und
deswegen auch einiges Gebiet aufgeben
z.B die Stadt AFD
und der Staatspräsident selenski sagt
ich bin Präsident der Ukraine ich gebe
grundsätzlich kein Gebiet auf und
außerdem habe ich es ständig mit
internationalen Partnern zu tun die
immer überreagieren und super nervös
werden und gleich alles verloren geben
wenn die Ukraine Gebiet aufgeben muss
also wie soll man da jetzt entscheiden
was da richtig ist beide Seiten haben
gute Argumente aber das führt natürlich
immer wieder aus den unterschiedlichen
Rollen heraus zu Spannungen stellt sich
aber trotzdem die Frage warum saluschni
jetzt gehen soll also warum zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt der Bürgermeister von Kiev
klitschko hat ja angedeutet dass
selenski in salusni möglicherweise auch
einen einen politischen Konkurrenten
sehen
könnte ja man könnte in dieser Frage die
ja Bestandteil von vielen Spekulationen
ist ja auch genau das umgedrehte
Argument machen wenn er in ihn in ihm
einen politischen Konkurrenten sieht
dann muss er ihn in seinen Diensten
behalten weil dann kann saluschni nicht
frei agieren und dann ist er unter
Kontrolle wenn er ihn entließe und Herr
saluschni würde frei in den Medien
agieren können ohne irgendwo eingebunden
zu sein wäre das ja möglicherweise für
Herrn selenski viel gefährlicher ich
weiß auch nicht ob diese Spekulationen
wirklich stimmen was die Konkurrenz
angeht was ich auf jeden Fall weiß und
wozu man den Ukrainern auch nur raten
kann ist dass solche wahltaktischen und
umfragetaktischen Spielchen gerade in
der Ukraine vollkommen fehlerm Platz
sind und sich da gegenseitig versuchen
mit Blick auf Umfragen irgendwie in
bestimmte Positionen zu bringen ist
deswegen falsch weil es ja um die Frage
geht gibt's überhaupt ein Land in dem
man gewählt werden kann und das wäre
schon gut wenn jetzt da die Akteure
wieder zusammen finden und wenn diese
Phase der Unsicherheit beendet wird aber
selenski geht ja eigentlich tatsächlich
sogar noch einen Schritt weiter er denkt
ja nicht nur darüber nach saluschni
auszutauschen sondern er kann sich auch
einen Wechsel in der politischen
Führungsebene m vorstellen wir hören mal
kurz rein was er in dem Interview mit
Rei gesagt
hat es ist eine Angelegenheit die die
Menschen betrifft die die Ukraine führen
müssen mit Sicherheit brauchen wir einen
neustaat das ist notwendig damit meine
ich eine ganze Reihe von Änderungen an
der Spitze des Staates und zwar nicht
nur in einem Bereich wie den
militärsektor ich denke über einen
neustaat nach aber wer
weiß also was bezweckt selenski damit
wenn er so laut über generell über diese
personellen Veränderungen nachdenkt und
vielleicht noch mal die Frage warum
macht er es überhaupt so
öffentlich ja in der Ukraine kommt das
sehr schlecht an dass er öffentlich
darüber nachdenkt und vor allen Dingen
dass er das in einem ausländischen
Medium macht äh die ukrainische
Zivilgesellschaft die ja sehr
selbstbewusst ist aber insgesamt alle
die in der Ukraine politisch aktiv sind
die erwarten eigentlich dass ihr
gewählter Präsident das mit ihnen
bespricht was er vorhat grundsätzlich
ist es so wenn der Präsident die
Regierung umgestalten will er hat qua
ukrainischer Verfassung die Möglichkeit
einen Premierminister zu bestimmen und
der bildet dann eine Regierung und der
Präsident hat Vollmachten was den
Verteidigungsminister und den
Außenminister betrifft also es ist nicht
so dass er da alle beliebig tauschen
kann ähm wenn er das machen will äh dann
wird ihm jeder zugestehen dass er das
auch machen kann und es sind sicherlich
auch in vielen Bereichen Veränderungen
nötig und vielleicht sind nach zwei
Jahren Krieg auch bei einigen gewisse
Ermüdungserscheinung da das ist ja
vielleicht auch normal aber der Stil ist
etwas der in der was in der Ukraine
gerade sehr kritisiert wird und ich kann
auch verstehen warum kommen wir noch mal
kurz auf diesen Konflikt zwischen den
beiden über denen wir ja eigentlich nur
mutmaßen können zurück aber wir wollen
versuchen ihn zu verstehen also
saluschni sieht die Ukraine ja im Moment
eher in einer
partsituation selenski will nicht von
dem Ziel abrücken
dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnen
muss gäbe es da überhaupt noch irgendwie
Möglichkeiten von diesen von diesen
beiden Punkten den Konflikt zu
überwinden und überhaupt weiter
zusammenzuarbeiten was general salusni
im conomist geschrieben hat war ja nicht
dass es eine patsituation gibt sondern
dass er wenn er nicht weitere Ressourcen
bekommt weiteres Material weitere
Munition weitere mobil gemachte Soldaten
dass er dann nur bis zu einem Pad
kämpfen können wird und da sind auch die
Punkte genannt um die der Konflikt sich
gerade dreht ich habe das schon gesagt
die Frage gibt man weil man weniger
Ressourcen hat zumindest vorläufig
bestimmte Abschnitte verloren um die
Front zu begradigen um dann mit weniger
Ressourcen auf weniger Kilometern Front
sich zu verteidigen macht man neue
soldatenmobil und wer macht das das ist
ja im Moment etwas das ein unangenehmes
Thema ist für alle Beteiligten aber wenn
der Präsident denit die Frage der
Mobilmachung zuschiebt die mobil das
Militär sagt wir brauchen Leute wir
wissen auch wofür aber das ist eine
politische Aufgabe dann geht's natürlich
dort nicht voran und das ist das
Missliche an diesem Streit dass er von
der Sache nämlich wie kann die Ukraine
sich weiter verteidigen und was kann die
Ukraine tun um sich militärisch
durchzusetzen dass er von dieser Sache
wegführt sie haben es eben angesprochen
den Mangel an Munition an Waffen dieser
angekündigte mögliche Wechsel in der
Führungsebene sowohl politisch als auch
militärisch
welches Signal sendet das an die
westlichen Unterstützer der
Ukraine ja die westlichen Unterstützer
werden jetzt glaube ich nicht für sich
beanspruchen dass sie die
Personalpolitik des ukrainischen
Staatspräsidenten auch noch mitmachen
wollen und ich glaube dass viele sich
auch mit Recht zurückhalten in der Frage
können wir da jetzt von der Seitenlinie
noch Ratschläge geben was zelenski tun
soll oder nicht er hat auch während
dieses Krieges bereits ein mal den
Verteidigungsminister ausgetauscht und
wenn man sich anguckt was es im
Verteidigungsbereich immer noch für
Probleme gibt mit Korruption was es für
Probleme gibt mit der Mobilmachung ist
es ja vielleicht auch gut nach zwei
Jahren Krieg dass da mal neue Ideen
reinkommen und das mag ja in anderen
Bereichen auch der Fall sein also ich
glaube auch bei den Partnern wird
niemand in Frage stellen dass der
Ukraine ukrainische Präsident das Recht
hat Personal zu tauschen wenn er das für
richtig hält dafür ist er gewählter
Präsident aber der Stil dieser
Diskussion und eine tagelange
Hängepartie das ist dieser Situation
nicht
angemessen letzte Frage noch mal ein
Perspektivwechsel wie dürften diese
ganzen Überlegungen beim russischen
Präsidenten Putin ankommen ja wladimir
Putin hat seine ganz eigenen Probleme
aber natürlich ist es so wenn sich in
der Ukraine daraus ein Streit entwickeln
sollte ein wirklicher Konflikt
entwickeln sollte dann wird Putin
versuchen daraus irgendwas zu machen das
zu instrumentalisieren den Konflikt
weiter anzuschüren und das ist ja auch
ein Grund warum man solche Dinge
vermeiden sollte schnell zu einem Ende
der Diskussion kommen muss um sich dann
gemeinsam auf die Verteidigung der
Ukraine zu
konzentrieren wladimir Putin hat aber
mit Bezug auf seine sogenannte Wahl im
März und das Schlechte laufen der
Militäroperation aus seiner Sicht glaube
ich auch seine ganz eigenen Probleme zu
lösen